[Music]
it's been a tough few years for the
american west due to extreme weather 90
percent of the region is in a worsening
drought according to the u.s drought
monitor with conditions in many areas
ranging from severe to exceptional
that's made water hard to come by for
those who rely on agriculture for their
living leading some farmers to rely on a
centuries-old tradition to find out
where to look carter evans has more
you see that
that's really good with a pair of bent
steel rods and a feeling and see when it
crosses like that there's water in that
direction rob thompson is on the hunt
for water underground i'm a water witch
or a dowser a doodle bugger diviner he
spends most of his time in drought
stricken california how's business for
you these days all my life i've never
had it this busy water witching has been
documented as far back as the 17th
century and its validity has been
debated ever since rob thompson is a
well-known dowser located in the heart
of sonoma napa wine country in
promotional videos online thompson says
he's a modern day practitioner even
dowsing on maps before getting out in
the field but then there's a second
strata we watched him witching in doug
hill's vineyards where they recently had
to cut way back on the napa city water
they used to irrigate 12 acres of grapes
what about next year next year they're
saying they won't guarantee any water
none zero
he's already drilling one of the
locations thompson identified you never
know until you put the hole in the
ground and figure it out thompson's
customers include popular wineries like
kendall jackson and gallow and we
confirmed they're happy with his work
but even thompson can't explain exactly
why witching works for him my theory is
that we're kind of like a radio and
we're tuning into the electromagnetic
fields of the earth we got something
there there is no science to back that
up but thompson does sometimes work in
conjunction with geologists and
hydrologists
at doug hill's vineyard they hit water
at about 400 feet deep but the quality
isn't good enough the well cost twelve
thousand dollars to dig and the drill
rig isn't available again for months
what do you typically say to people who
doubt you
i usually hand them a pair of rods
so you feel that yeah
so what are you telling me you're over a
water source here the rods did move but
i don't know what i'm feeling for
what it is is your mind sending a signal
to your motor muscular system to
actually close those rods
he's right
psychologists call those tiny muscle
twitches idiom motor movements they're
caused by subconscious mental activity
see where it crosses like that over 30
years of dowsing thompson claims his
findings have resulted in 4 000 wells
this water spot is right here the only
way to find out if he's right this time
is to dig another well that will cost
tens of thousands of dollars well worth
it to doug hill if he finds the water
that will save his vineyard for cbs
mornings i'm carter evans in napa valley
vlad's a doubter well if it wasn't for
the 4 000 whales i think i would be too
but four thousand come on i can doubt it
says carter carter basically said there
is no science to back it up four
thousand flat four thousand dollars
everything is not about science okay all
right have a little faith
[Laughter]